*soupir*
J'appréhende de faire cette vidéo
*rire*
Je vous explique depuis que je suis jeune j'ai une malédiction, à chaque fois il n'y a pas une année qui passe sans que quelqu'un m'offre
un
casse-tête.
Je sais pas pourquoi.
Alors c'est cool, c'est un cadeau donc c'est cool, c'est agréable mais il y'a comme un petit pique
Hop ! Un petit coup de couteau qui va avec
puisque les gens savent que j'adore la difficulté mais savent aussi que je suis pas patient du tout
et que j'suis un gros rageux.
Je dois vous avouer quelque chose là, tous ceux qui m'ont offert ça dans ma vie
à la fois j'espère vous regardez la vidéo,
à la fois j'espère vous la regardez pas,
je n'en ai jamais fini
UN SEUL !!!
Arrêtez de m'offrir des casses-têtes, je ne sais pas les finir !
Aujourd'hui,
c'est un peu comme ce que j'ai fait avec le dessin,
d'ailleurs la vidéo vous a archi plu celle sur le dessin donc je suis trop content
c'était vraiment
un test je me suis dit les gens vont pas aimer mais au moins moi je me serais dépassé,
je me serais fait plaisir.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai acheté 4 casse-têtes qui sont PAS facile,
donc pour moi impossible de les finir.
J'ai pas pris des casse têtes qu'on m'a offert parce que j'ai déjà trop ragé dessus etc et ça va me saoûler
et j'préfère découvrir avec vous le casse tête et c'est des casse têtes plus ou moins originaux avec des mécaniques
différentes et en tout cas qui m'inspire qui me donne envie d'essayer donc c'est déjà ça de pris. Casse tête numéro un on y va
*musique joyeuse*
Bon voici le premier casse-tête il s'agit du "Hezzel" c'est une clé dans une clé est donc là la mécanique c'est...  il faut le
désassembler les ré-assembler je crois que celui-là il est très très très connus donc peut-être qu'un certains d'entre vous le connaissent et j'aimerais bien le finir très
vite très rapidement. Alors deux clés et le but c'est de les sortir et de les remettre ouais ok il faut réussir à le faire basculer
voyez ça c'est l'étape 1
c'est l'étape qu'on est un peu passionné donc ça se présente comme ça à mon avis le truc c'est vous savez c'est les trucs de rotation
on tourne depuis du coup ça passe puis on peut on peut passer l'autre côté puis machin puis ça finit par se désassembler
ça c'est l'analyse d'un expert des casse tête ça se voit n'est ce pas déjà j'ai un réflexe bizarre j'ai envie de tirer
j'ai envie de tirer comme ça très fort
un bon réflexe de gros rageux de merde hein n'est ce pas quand la clé à la verticale ça passe là
quand la clé et à l'horizontale ça passe nul part on peut pas passer de l'autre côté parce que la boule est trop grande
voyez ça bloque de l'autre côté on peut passer que de ce côté là mais une fois qu'on est là
Mais je ne sais pas quoi faire ça c'est fait pour arriver là mais quand tu arrives là à quoi ça sert
Et dans l'autre sens
AH OUAH il vient de se passer quelque chose là regardez je vous remonte soit je mets comme ça et je peux passer là ce
qui nous a amenés à rien
soit je lève la clé je peux passer là et là c'est une nouvelle étape quoi ça nous sert de passer là je comprends pas
puisqu'on peut pas passer la bon bref fois la clé à la verticale elle peut passer partout attends
attends...tends...tends QUOI
Attend il s'est passé quoi là j'ai réussi à la mettre comme ça je passe la première barre mais pas la deuxième
Je suis en train de tirer...Toujours plus simple de tirer que de réfléchir ça c'est une règle toujours beaucoup plus simple attend mec mais j'ai réussi
à aller là mais ça sert à rien
AH MAIS NON OK je reviens je le fais dans l'autre sens j'ai compriiiis
Pas du tout en fait ok c'est ça mon problème je fais plein de trucs comme ça huug guigui et j'espère que ça
passe et je suis je sais pas où ça mène ce que je fais mais j'espère que ça mène au fait que les deux trucs
se désassemblent mais en réalité à la fin je n'aurais même pas compris comment j'ai fait c'est ça qui est débile c'est idiot  mec attendez donc
déjà tout a l'heure j'avais réussi à amener la clé sur la barre principale qui est là donc je pense que ça c'est ce qui mène à
la à la solution
ça on peut repasser et là on passe la voilà je pense que ça c'est le début ce que je comprends pas c'est que la
clé elle passe la première barre mais elles passent pas la deuxième barre voyez si bizarre
est-ce que c'est fait exprès parce que là si je passe cette deuxième barre là je passe au bout c'est fini
Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas quelque chose avec le haut D'LA CLEE Y'A UN TRUC AVEC LE HAUT DE LA CLEE
OK une fois qu'on est arrivé en haut de la clé il faut la tourner je suppose
OUAH mec je suis en train de perdre le contrôle je sais plus tout ce que je suis en train de faire avec cette clé
OUUUUH OUUH OUUH OUH OUH OUH OUH
OHHHHHHH
CALM DAWN calm dawn j'ai réussi à le désassembler pour montrer que tu as compris me casse tête il faut être capable de le ré assembler
je vais te le réassembler en deux temps trois mouvements mon petit pote donc je sais que l'entrée c'est là
steuplé,  steuplé...
Donc tu commences avec les deux clés comme ça je fais ça puis ça puis la normalement  tu peux passer ici ou ici
Merde oh non la honte
Je ne sais pas comment j'ai fait
attends je vais re-check le rush voir et voilà pourquoi je n'arrivais pas à faire les casse tête pendant tout ce temps il
faut que je me filme à pouvoir me souvenir de ce que j'ai fait
c'est vraiment de la triche
*musique d'ascenseur*
Bon après analyse des images
regardez pourquoi je n'arrivais pas à le remettre parce que je m'obstine à vouloir leur mettre dans ce sens là
et du coup on fait ça passe nulle part latéralement en fait il faut le remettre dans ce sens là l'autre sens et là
hop ça passe
Voilà là ça passe on revient là une fois qu'on est là on retourne la clé voilà une fois que la clé retournée
On passe on repasse bon ben voilà vous avez saisi l'idée quoi
*musique d'ascenseur*
Bon réanalyse des images je vous montre comment on fait pour le remonter en gros ici il faut voir ça comme un petit portail et
il ya des trucs que j'avais pas vu au premier abord mais c'est par exemple cette barre elle est plus fine en bas qu'elle ne
l'est en haut donc en fait on peut sortir la clé par en bas mais pas par en haut et c'est  plein de petits détails comme ça
c'est vraiment bien fait je découvre ce que c'est quoi un casse tête bien foutu donc l'entrée du casse tête quand on veut
le recomposer c'est bien évidemment là où on est sorti donc c'est la
hop
une fois qu'on a mis on le fait passer là une fois qu'ils passe là on retourne de ce côté là j'en arrive là
une fois qu'on est là on fait ça une fois qu'on est là on tourne la clé pour pouvoir passer de l'autre côté
une fois qu'on est passé de l'autre côté ont rerentre une fois qu'on est rerentré on repasse là on retourne au point de départ
et chuis un tueur j'ai fini le premier casse tête de ma viiiiiiiie
"côassement de corbeau x2"
C'est l'heure du deuxième casse tête
*musique joyeuse*
Est ce que cette vidéo est intéressant elle est très peu selon moi!
*rire*
je suis honnête avec vous mais bon vous voyez rager après tout ça depuis 2014 c'est quelque chose qui
Aller
*musique joyeuse*
Alors ça mon pote ça je sais que c'est horrible davinci
hélicoptère puzzle déjà le nom nous met pas du tout en confiance
ah ça c'est exactement ce que je déteste c'est tout le temps sur cela que j'ai rage est alors une fois résolue le puzzle sera
en trois pièces est ce que vous pouvez réussir à séparer l'hélicoptère
ok j'ai pas que léonard s'amusait à faire des casse têtes difficulté 3 sur 5 on note cette info on la note
alors on a une croix avec une petite pièce qui bouge là et au milieu là il ya un trou
ici bon bah le but du coup vous allez être surpris mais c'est de le démonter tout simplement ont déjà qu'est ce qui bouge là
on voit bien que ça c'est lié par le milieu
ça ça change de sens est ce que c'est un rectangle ou est ce que c'est un carré de peut être intéressant
Mais il est horrible mais c'est pas un casse tête c'est un objet de
décoration quoi on le met comme ça hop c'est un objet déco et on en parle plus quoi fin pourquoi les gens veulent se faire
chier à démonter il est très bien comme ça
elles sont emboîtés l'une dans l'autre là les deux planches vous voyez là il ya un trou dans ses là pour que cela puisse rentrer
et pareil de l'autre côté mais je comprends pas comment on est censé faire bouger les choses
un pour le moment je peux juste faire ça
'tain en fait il est redoutable parce qu'il est simple quoi il ya trois pièces
trois bouts de bois là à temps mais c'est ça les fameux bout de bois avec lesquels jouaient nos parents quand ils avaient le même
âge que nous c'est cela tu m'étonnes qu'ils ont passé leur enfance à jouer avec, ils ont jamais compris ça se trouve il ya un petit
bouton caché quelque part et quand on appuie dessus hop'sasa se disloque et on obtient 3 pièces laissez moi rêver on peut même pas les
pousser dans ce sens là où dans l'autre sens rien n'y fait c'est terrible ça vient forcément de la regarder le jeu qui à quoi
C'est très bizarre ce que je fais c'est juste une mécanique de merde à trouver c'est ça qui est fou avec les casse-tête c'est toujours ça ya juste un truc qui
est hors de son cercle de logique là et qui t'échappe
totalement qu'est ce que ce truc là vient foutre dans l'histoire
et pourquoi ils s'appellent hélicoptère à ce que vous trouvez que ça ressemble vraiment un hélicoptère suis pas sûr
*musique joyeuse*
Vous me pardonnerez tôt ou tard vous me pardonnerez pour ce que je vais faire
comment tu fais comment tu fais c'est quoi le truc qui m'a échappé s'te plaît me dis pas que c'est un truc tout con aucun
C'est un troll il est en train de nous trollé, l'étape 1 c'est de faire ça
Quoi ça aide en quoi?
Mais je me fais trollé c'est un 1er avril ça a été mis en ligne le 1er avril le 4 janvier on est très loin
d'un 1er avril ouais d'accord on est d'accord que premier degré
ça ne marche pas ça ne marche pas pour moi j'ai la solution sous les yeux et je n'y arrive pas allo
Mec ça me flingue j'ai la solution sous les yeux et je n'y arrive pas qu est ce qui se passe ici
Mec c'est de la folie ça fait quatre fois que je la regarde et que j'essaie et que j'arrive pas
vas- y mec, mec
*Bris de verre*
Mec j'ai la
j'ai la solution
sous les yeux et ça ne marche pas combien d'années m'aurait-il fallut, combien de vies m'aurait-il fallut pour y arriver
sans la solution sous les yeux
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOH
OOOOOOH
Achetez le achetez le fait le même si vous avez la soluce maintenant ça vaut le coup AH bordel de merde
mais quel enfer
mais du coup lucas
C'est quoi le tips on n'a pas compris
et bien moi non plus mais je vais essayer de vous l'expliquer en gros chaque bout là vous voyez vous voyez une barre en fer
il y en a une de chaque côté en fait vous voyez là on voit les deux par exemple y en a une qui sort
de la une qui sort de là et en gros chaque barre va venir
s'enfoncer dans les trous que ya de part et d'autre de l'autre pièce et quand tu fais le mouvement qui fait là
les deux bars à tour de rôle sorte de l'autre pièce ça permet finalement de pouvoir faire sortir l'une des deux pièces
voilà écouter moins bien je n'aurais jamais trouvé de toute mon existence c'est un 3 sur 5 la difficulté
CA DONNE QUOI UN 5?
casse-tête numéro....
HUUUN
je vais mourrir
*musique joyeuse*
Il m'en reste plein, regardez il m'en reste 3 quoi
9 SUR 10!!
le eureka attend 9 sur 10 ça va être des histoires de
nœuds, de trucs ça va être horrible celui là je l'aime bien parce qu'il est très minimaliste et pourtant je pense qu'il est
extrêmement dur juste une boule avec des pics qu'il faut réussir à faire sortir la boule il est horrible
juste le regard des sommes de mal au crâne ok et le dernier c'est une boîte
Et ben on va faire la boîte donc regarder que c'est juste une boîte chaque côté ce n'est pas
exactement la même forme que vous avez là le but c'est de les séparer on voit clairement qu'ya du jeu attendez je sais il faut
le prendre comme ça il faut
Excusez-moi
Mon cerveau de l'homme primitif a tendance à vouloir juste tirer comme ça
mais ça ne sert à rien, à mon avis il faut pousser d'un côté comme ça puis de l'autre puis de l'autre puis de l'autre 'fin à mon avis il est
pas du tout simple ce casse-tête façon plus il a l'air simple plus il est dur que c'est horrible parce tu sais pas par où
commencer quoi mec c'est une boîte quoi notamment tu mets deux bagues et des boucles d'oreilles dedans et on en parle plus
mais la est-ce qu'ya pas un truc de ressorts ou j'appuie et
Chuis un débile c'est bizarre mais vous avez une idée quand on tire ça marche pas forcément quand on veut faire une rotation
latéral ça marche pas non plus
Marche pas non plus non mais les trucs ou faut construire et déconstruire
Et que c'est en bois je vous jure c'est cela qui me traumatise j'vous jure le point commun de tous les casse tête qui me qui me rendent
malade c'est qu'ils sont en bois quoi je sais pas pourquoi
Voilà je commence avec les ongles dans les trous pour tirer fort c'est pas du tout bon signe ça mais je vais vous dire je
vais vous dire la vérité je
n'ai aucune putain d'idée de comment par où commencer même pas de comment faire ou de par quoi commencer c'est comme l'autre là-bas
attendez je vais tenter un truc
vous... vous me pardonnerez un jour, un jour vous me pardonnerez
mais pourquoi, il
Faut toujours frapper ou secouer est ce que c'est possible ne voit rien n'a frappé ou secouer
ça a marchééé
C'est trop pour moi
Bon explication on a donc deux parties est en fait dans chaque partie il ya un petit trou celui-là est profond celui là n'est pas
profond et on a une bille, la bille joue un rôle très important
puisqu'en fait pour remettre le casse tête tu la mets là il ya deux petits aimants au fond de chaque trou est en fait quand
on va leur mettre la bille va entrer à moitié dans l'autre trou ce qui fait qu'on pourra pas
séparer les bouts ce qui fait qu'il faut mettre un gros coup pour qu'elle passe dans la partie rouge donc pour refaire le casse tête
on remet la bille dans la partie rouge ça se glisse tout simplement en diagonale comme ça on
retourne on met un petit coup là où il ya la bille
voilà on a entendu un ptit clap et c'est
rebloqué c'est bien mais en fait ça me frustre parce que du coup au final il faut juste trouver
ben il faut juste trouver ou taper quoi c'est pas une mécanique qui moi m'amuse par exemple je me suis beaucoup plus s'amuser avec la
clé peut-être parce que je l'ai réussi et que je suis extrêmement de mauvaise foi actuellement
*musique joyeuse*
Les amis épreuve finale on va pas faire celui là on va faire le eureka
j'ai peut-être pris beaucoup fort la confiance en voyant la solution de des 2 trucs d'avant mais j'assume
on a donc une sculpture en bois avec un trou au milieu et une
ficelle chacune des extrémités est passé du coup a priori dans le tout fin c'est ce qu'on croit et bien entendu ni la boule qui
se trouve là ni la pièce qui est au bout
ah si ok les disques passent mais pas la boule donc comment on fait et on a en plus de ça un anneau en bas
il a l'air méga
dur, mec, OH LA VACHE!
Y'a un tour de magie qui est comme ça où c'est une ficelle tu fais un noeud et y'a un anneau qui est là au milieu et
en fait nos effets d'une telle façon ou en fait il est fait autour de l'anneau et du coup tu peux sortir
l'anneau voilà je sais pas si s'était très clair mais du coup je pense qu'il ya un délire dans ce genre là avec celui là
puisqu'on retrouve
l'anneau là et la ficelle et ça m'a tout de suite fait penser à ça donc je pense qu'il ya une corrélation en tout cas
je vais tout donner pour y arriver et j'espère vous faire honneur
peu importe le temps qu'il faudra je réserverai ce puzzle eurêka notée 9 sur 10 c'est parti
*musique*
Ah mec, c'était interminable mec bon vous avez hâte de voir la solution et j'ai hâte de vous la montrer
parce ce que le but bien sûr c'est que je vous montre comment faire pour le remonter bien sûr on l'a dit au début on
n'a pas résolu à casse-tête si on n'arrive pas à le remonter
parce que ça peut être de la chance alors écoutez c'est très simple vous allez juste prendre l'anneau posé l'anneau sur la corde vous
allez appuyer bien fort avec votre doigt ici sur le palais et dans l'anneau avec vos deux index vous allez tirer sur la corde
voilà à partir de là c'est plutôt simple vous remettez l'anneau sur le sur l'objet
vous retirez la boule qui pose problème depuis le départ vous passez votre petite ficelle dans l'objet vous mettez la boule vous remettez le disque
et c'est terminé merci à tous à bientôt
bon blague à part merci déjà d'avoir suivi cette vidéo que je retiens quand même c'est que j'ai réussi à finir un casse-tête et s'était
jamais arrivé avant je vous assure alors oui la difficulté c'est que 2 sur 6 mais bon il faut bien commencer quelque part
mais j'ai quand même réussi à faire celui là donc rester tranquille restez à votre place
ok vous m'en direz des nouvelles quand vous l'aurez fini en vrai je suis content parce que j'ai découvert des mécaniques par exemple le fait de
devoir taper ou de devoir secoué dans le cas de le de l'hélico merde et chuis un rageux
jusqu'à la fin je suis désolé je suis comme ça un casse-tête plus classiques comme celui là j'ai réussi à finir alors oui c'est plus
simple je suis quand même content parce que je l'ai fais sans tricher et là ya pas de de
mécanique caché à comprendre tout est sous tes yeux c'est juste des chemins à
prendre des rotations à trouver j'ai beaucoup apprécié donc je pense dans un premier temps je me dirigeais plus vers ce genre de casse tête
là et j'ai mettre de côté ceux là mais le fait d'en avoir fini 1
enfin après tant d'années me donne envie d'en essayer d'autres je sais pas si t'es cool pour vous mais ça m'a fait marrer j'ai découvert
des mécaniques des trucs improbable en ce moment je me sers de ma chaîne YouTube pour prendre sur moi sur des trucs qui m'ont toujours
frustré voilà
La première vidéo comme ça c'était celle avec le dessin la deuxième c'est avec les casse-têtes la troisième qu'est ce que ce sera je ne
sais pas aller pas de casse tête pour noël vous avez bien entendu
ceux qui me connaissent la pâte casse tête pour noël OK? est ce que je fais une vidéo sur machine pour faire passer un message
à 7 personnes ? oui !
petite aide par: felixio2020 (YT)
*musique entraînante*